tom Fitton runs judicial watch as you
well know cuz he's a frequent guest on
the show he's been watching all this and
he joins us tonight what's the takeaway
for you Tom well it's a terrible day for
the Constitution in the country the
president has been terribly abused or
constitutions being attacked and you
know taking a step back we have
information that the United States
government more or less was lying to us
for three years about Russia collusion
by the way about Afghanistan and UFOs
and fill in the blanks the food pyramid
I mean do you know what I mean like all
the things we're not talking about right
I put the lies were designed to put this
man in jail yes and he's been completely
exonerated and vindicated and he was
starting to ask you questions about what
went on in Ukraine as it was related to
that and now the same gang that lied
about him and tried to put him Jail
illegally it's now impeaching him for
asking questions about it and impeaching
him for defending himself in response to
their obsessive activities with regard
to trying to get his people that's right
and I look I hate to degress I'm
throwing this that you called you'll be
forgiven if you don't want to answer it
but it's a sincere question why does
Trump threaten these people so much what
because this is irrational it's hurting
them they're doing it anyway they're
clearly in some kind of psychological
state unhealthy state but it stems from
the fact that he threatens them they
look at him and it's fight or flight why
is that they see him as a revolutionary
reformist figure on these issues that
you have highlighted on foreign policy
on the role of government in our lives
on the nostrums that we are all supposed
to be falling down around it's right
here in Washington DC
Oh foreign aid let's all fall down there
not any question I'll ask you any
questions about how it's spent having
someone got armed Ukraine that's wrong
we have to arm you right there's one
thing you know there's one thing
Jefferson and Madison agreed on arm
Ukraine we had the FISA Court yesterday
say they can't believe the FBI on
anything and this man is being impeached
for asking questions about that parties
the Democratic Party's potential
political nominee presidential nominee
this is what it's about it's about
protecting Joe Biden it's about
protecting themselves from the
consequences of their criminal behavior
they're nervous that the DOJ has begun
asking questions and in many ways this
is a mass of
direction of justice and I tell you the
president needs to be sure that his
defense is a lot stronger than he's
allowed it to be thus far that's right
because this impeachment didn't have to
happen he should have been defended more
strongly legally and the Senate trial I
don't know how it's gonna turn out but
he but those who support the rule of law
need to push back hard on this yeah and
the irony is of course they'd been
posturing all day about the rule of all
even as they work tirelessly to subvert
it tom Fitton
great to see you tonight thank you as
you said the president has been speaking
in Battle Creek Michigan
I think he's continuing to speak I think
he's speaking at this moment but he
hasn't addressed impeachment he
addressed it for about 45 seconds
earlier tonight and he addressed it
again also for about 45 seconds just a
moment ago we rolled on that as well we
want to bring it to you now with today's
illegal unconstitutional and partisan
impeachment they do not think Democrats
and they are do-nothing all they want to
do is focus on this what they could be
doing are declaring their deep hatred
and disdain for the American voter this
lawless partisan impeachment is a
political suicide March for the Democrat
Party have you seen my polls in the last
four weeks
it's crazy you know why because people
you know we have an election right down
the road president states Battle Creek
Michigan